>>Narrator: Physical education
has long been synonymous
with running laps, jumping
jacks, and competitive sports.
But an increasing number of schools
are taking a fresh new approach
to PE.
At San Rafael High School in Northern
California PE is all about fitness,
fun, and high-flying adventure.
>>C.J.: The new physical
education is getting kids
to understand why they
are doing things.
You know, not just barking orders
but also helping them learn
and understand how their
bodies work, why it's important
to have this understanding
throughout their lives.
We try to get buy-in from the kids
and we try to implement the fitness
and the exercise into
games and activities
where they're actually moving
their bodies and getting in shape
but they're also having fun.
>>Narrator: Technology helps
to individualize the workouts.
>>C.J.: The watch is recording
the heart rate and the strap
under their shirts is picking it up.
>>Narrator: Healy uses a PDA to
take attendance and make notes
and adds the heart rate data to each
student's individual sportfolio.
>>C.J.: The beaming device just takes
the data off the watch and sends it
to the computer which
plots it on a graph.
>>So here is Juan's fitness results.
>>Okay so you're going to
untie by working together
and you can discuss the
strategy if you need to.
>>Narrator: Most classes
include a cooperative challenge
like untying a human knot.
>>C.J.: We put them into groups
where they're with students
of all different races and
backgrounds and languages
and we give them challenges and
we give them problems to solve.
>>Student: Put your
arm down and walk over.
>>C.J.: You know in the case of kids
who don't speak the same language,
they have to find other ways to
communicate to solve the problem.
>>Student: There you go, yeah.
>>Judith: If you have to do it as
team and there are all these rules
as to how you do it, you're in the
problem-solving and critical thinking
and whether or not we put those
words to it at that moment,
that's what they're doing.
Those are essential
skills in the classroom
and everything we do in life.
>>Student: There we go!
>>Student: You got it.
>>C.J.: When the challenge is over
whether they're successful or not,
you always bring them back together.
You always debrief.
Get them to think about
what they've done.
>>Good, Juan?
>>Juan: We communicated.
>>C.J.: You communicated.
>>Student: We didn't give up.
>>C.J.: You didn't give up, okay.
>>Student: Everyone's
pulse rate quickens
as students don helmets
and gather ropes gear.
>>Narrator: I can't go
any higher, I'm scared.
>>Narrator: The school's
adventure room was the brainchild
of former P.E. teacher, Bill Monti.
>>Bill: This is real to the kids.
I mean the risk factors are there.
They see them and they
are afraid of them.
However in all situations they
are being belayed or safe-guarded
by either a rope that's
fixed or a rope
that is being belayed
by a team-member.
>>Student: Sit parallel,
sit parallel to the wall.
>>Chevoy: You have people
like, you know, helping you.
They don't just watch you.
They help you through
every step you're doing.
You get along with everybody.
>>Bill: We have leaders that emerge
because they maybe have
a little more confidence
or maybe they've had success sooner
than someone else in the group,
and so with that experience
they share it
with the other members of the team.
>>Student: Safe, make it safe.
>>Bill: So we really
do teach leadership.
>>Juan: This is like one of the
best P.E. classes I've ever been to.
I'm mostly a leader in my class.
When someone is not following
directions I mostly guide them
to the right way.
>>Ruth: It's more about teamwork and
making sure you don't screw and end
up falling on something, but
mostly the trust is a big one.
>>Teacher: Alright, understand?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Narrator: Adventure
P.E. is catching
on in schools across the country.
New teachers at New Jersey's
Montclair State University are
learning how to impart
new P.E. skills.
>>Teacher: This one goes
a little bit faster, guys.
Take your time, slowly.
Very good.
>>Carolyn: Everyone here
ends up learning a little bit
about everyone else
in a different way
than just skill-related
athletic stuff like power
and agility and quickness.
>>Teacher: Very slowly.
>>Carolyn: Because everybody has a
chance to put in what they need to do
and communicate together as a team.
>>Student: You can go first.
Do you want to go second?
>>Carolyn: They can learn some
of the character education values
that you need like integrity
and justice and responsibility
and all those kinds of things that
it's very hard to teach in school.
>>Student: Ready guys?
>>Student: Are you ready, Maddie?
>>Student: Yep.
>>Student: Step on, step on.
>>Carolyn: I'll ask them where
did they use these skills
that you're learning today in life?
>>Student: And the first thing they
said "We can use this in school."
And we're like "How?"
>>Student: They said "Working
on projects in order to have--
get a good grade on projects everyone
has to put equal amount of effort."
>>Student: And they said if
they didn't talk together
when they were doing a project,
they'd both do the same thing
by accident and wouldn't
get the job done.
So I mean they were able to
apply it outside of the gym.
>>Teacher: You're almost
to the bucket.
>>Narrator: As some schools cut
back on P.E. and after-school sports
in pursuit of higher test scores,
others see the positive effects
of exercise on mind and body.
>>Kira: Let's see if we can
help each other balance.
>>Narrator: In the Bronx, Kira Morton
teachers her first graders yoga.
>>Kira: Fly like a butterfly.
>>Students: Fly like a butterfly.
>>Kira: I do yoga with
the kids every single day.
The kids really respond well to it.
I found last year that my kids
were very jumpy and it was
like the perfect thing
to get them settled down.
>>Sit up nice and tall, bring
your hands on your belly.
Breath in.
Ommmmmm...
>>It also helps me,
it helps me breathe.
It helps me remember that
they are 5, 6, 7 years old.
We do need to find time for movement.
>>And drive.
>>Narrator: In Napa, California,
Sharon Campbell attached
a wind turbine
to a stationary bike
allowing her seventh graders
to generate electricity while
they burn off excess energy.
>>Sharon: I think every
classroom needs the bicycle even
if they don't have the
energy bank the way we do,
because I have youngsters
in here that will be working
on their project, stand up and
go over and peddle for five
or six minutes and come
and sit down again.
And they haven't even
thought about making power.
They haven't thought about
the fact they can't sit still
for another minute.
They just automatically go and
they burn off a little energy.
>>Joel: Kids spend their time
in school sitting down, okay,
and that is by far the
worst thing you can do
for a kid and for learning.
>>You're going to start turning
like this where your arms just flop
against your body like that.
>>Narrator: A former
sports psychologist
for the San Francisco Giants, Kirsch
believes students could benefit
from doing a few simple
exercises in class.
>>Joel: These are techniques
related to balance, concentration,
flexibility, maintaining a
positive attitude, all the things
that are needed to
help the student learn.
When kid are working on a written
assignment for quite a long period
of time, they can just get off and do
these off to the side by themselves
to wake themselves up,
oxygenate their blood and go back
to their desk and continue
their work.
You know, as long as you allow
that flexibility in the classroom.
>>Good job, you guys are pros.
>>Narrator: Kirsch is planning
to open a public school
that will place sports and wellness
at the center of the curriculum.
>>Joel: Seventy-five percent
of high school students
across the country are quote
unquote "chronically disengaged".
At the same time all the research is
showing that kids are totally engaged
when they're involved in
activities like sports.
So what we're looking to do is bring
the positive aspects of sport culture
into a total learning environment
and in an entire school setting.
>>Narrator: Kirsch's vision
is similar to programs
at Harrison High School
in Mississippi.
Here blood pressure readings from the
school's championship cheerleading
squad are entered into a database
which is accessed by math students.
Other students learn
physics principles
that will enhance their
sports performance.
>>Teacher: If you consider a
minute ago you went from up there
to the floor in a 30th of a second,
so your acceleration
was a lot faster.
>>C.J.: Being trustworthy but
also trusting other people,
solving problems, working in teams,
and taking risks are really
important skills that kids need
to learn somewhere to be successful.
What we do in physical education
program is more important now
than it ever was.
It's so great to see these
girls come in sort of quiet,
a little meek at the
beginning of the year,
and then to see them jumping
off the wall on the zip line.
>>Student: [squeals]
>>C.J.: The transformation
is amazing.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.